well thank you all for for being here
and taking the time to take a course
like this so it's sort of my my life's
work is entrepreneurship engineering
climate change so it's great to be her
and I appreciate being invited so what i
thought i would do today is just talk to
you about dbl and cleantech investing
and all that it represents and both sort
of past present and future I did get
some great questions from folks what I
wasn't able to look at until this
morning and I've tried to incorporate
answers into my remarks but if if i
don't answer them we can do that at the
end but please feel free to interrupt me
at any time with a question as you hear
about and what what this is what the way
we look at clean tech because it's fine
with me des to have an interactive
session and so just for those of you
that don't know about dbl we spun out of
JP Morgan in 2008 and where I had worked
for many many years as a venture
capitalist and the dbl stands for double
bottom line we invest for both talk to
your financial returns as well as
driving social economic and
environmental improvement and we think
that you can do both and that one you
don't have to sacrifice one for the
other and that is what we've done now
for over 12 years we were kind of impact
investors before that that term was was
widely known and we're we're kind of
considered one of the pioneers and we in
turn we take a pretty broad definition
one of your questions someone wrote to
me was you know is it about the
communities is it about the the
workforce having a good job good
conditions is about the product actually
helping society and the answer to that
it's really all of the above we weave in
a portfolio you can accomplish all of
that you can have a company like Tesla
that's of course from you
it's listening to mark last week you
know is developing a product that helps
move our planet away from fossil fuel
but it also it also helps create jobs in
tremont when in a place where when that
the nummi plant that it took over had
been shuttered that was 5,000 jobs that
were lost several years ago so there's
all we across our portfolio of
investments we have great products that
are going to change the world for the
better we have wonderful workplace
practices which I'll tell you a little
bit about and we have community impact
as well as policy leadership I'll say
that you can't really be an impact
investor if you're if you're afraid of
policy afraid of jumping in because it's
it's just vital to making all of this
work and so we spend a lot of time on
that last week one of my partner's was
spent the day at the California Public
Utilities Commission which oh no in San
Francisco because net metering is sort
of another question from one of you is a
big issue right now and you know if you
ever told me that one of my colleagues
would be sitting in the PUC auditorium
all day that's part of being a venture
capitalist i'm not sure what it
predicted that but it's the kind of
stuff we do and i'll tell you why so
when we started dbl we you know we
didn't know how big and kind of how bold
impact investing cleantech investing was
to become and and just to give you an
example when we wrote the investment map
memo for Tesla way back in 2006 we we
kind of I mean in every investment mummy
you say Oh it'll be able to go public I
mean obviously that's our job is to get
exits like that and what I don't know if
Mark told you what the model s used to
be called it was the white star that was
its code name and so we I read the
investment memo a few weeks ago and we
just said well if they make the white
star we think they'll make that'll be a
big enough product so that they'll be
able to go public and we'll we'll make
our returns that will be great our
downside scenario which you always have
to put in an investment memo was
remember they had the roadster which was
the two-seater
and we said well if that's all they ever
get around to making if the White Star
really doesn't happen and the Roadster
was called the Dark Star so we said well
even then they could get quired by like
a luxury car manufacturer like
Lamborghini or Ferrari that wanted to
have a product for the eco-minded luxury
car consumer and so and so we thought
what we wouldn't make a lot of money
then but at least we wouldn't lose
everything and so that was kind of what
what our investment mento memo predicted
we didn't believe that downside scenario
you know you never do or else why would
you make the investment but we thought
we were covered we took a lot of flack
for investing in Tesla from our
colleagues because silicon valley you
know doesn't invest in car companies and
certainly didn't back then and so it was
you know it wasn't the most comfortable
feeling to be questioned by all of my
peers but you know we we we had this
mission we climate change was at the
center of what we wanted to invest
around so you know we went ahead and did
and did that and of course today 12
years later Tesla is worth about 35
billion dollars it's about half the
market capitalization of GM which was
founded 108 years ago so Tesla which is
about 10 years old is already half as
valuable as GM so that tells you
something so anyway that's Tesla and
that's GM and it's a pretty amazing
statistic so before I talk about the
Solar City side of it so very similarly
before Solar City was founded in 2006
2006 we had invested in a company called
in the year before a company called
power light which is what at the time
was were the largest commercial
installers they put the solar on the
Moscone Center for example a very long
time ago and
I just remember after making that
investment a partner at a very storied
venture firm took me out to dinner at
the Woodside pub and just kind of said
you know Nancy that's that that power
light that's kind of a construction
company that's not what venture
capitalists really invest in you know go
back I had done a lot of life science
and IT investing he said go back to that
because this is not really what we're
all about and you know if you are if you
do have to invest in clean tech get
something that has something proprietary
like some really fancy technology and
not just a bunch of people putting solar
panels on rooftops and so of course that
was somewhat jarring to me and I made
the case for what we did need to clean
up our electricity grid if we were going
to deal with climate change and that
should be a big business opportunity
because it's it's a bill you know
multi-billion dollar market but anyway
there was still a feeling that this was
not really what what we were paid to do
well so then 18 months after that dinner
powerlite was sold to some power one of
the the giants in the solar industry for
345 million and that was we held that
that investment for less than two years
so it was a really good financial return
and it was one of the first big clean
tech VC exits so this that win gave us
the confidence to invest in solar city
which we thought I was kind of just a
residential version of power light I
mean they were both putting panels on
rooftops one was for commercial
buildings and SolarCity was destined for
mostly residences at that time and again
lots of skepticism but today SolarCity
as you see here is a four billion dollar
public company it's a quarter the size
of one of the one of its kind of
competitors one of the incumbents PG&E
which is in turn one of the largest
investor-owned utilities in our country
and again it was founded you know coming
up on its 10th anniversary whereas PG&E
was started a few years earlier even
than the general motors so this really
shows you that we're in the middle of
this very very kind of once in a
generation change and that the icons of
the 20th century are eventually going to
go away or be modified in the way that
we look at them and replaced with icons
of our own century and that's pretty
pretty exciting so today I just want to
give you a few statistics on the solar
industry the surprise some folks the
solar industry employs more than the
coal industry does even though you hear
how important coal is to this country
Solar has more employees 174,000 last
year that's more than Google Facebook
Twitter and Salesforce combined and
that's something that a lot of people
don't know of course we love all those
companies and very important to all of
us but they don't hire that many people
and that's something that's the clean
tech industry has kind of a nation its
hand that it does employ people when you
make stuff when you install stuff you
actually get more numbers so that the
solar industry employs of roughly about
the same number of people as Amazon as a
company which you know is one of the
largest tech companies out there it also
employs more than the utility industry
SolarCity just in California there are
55 thousand solar workers and that's
more than all of the big five utilities
in California combined so PG nice Ocala
at sempra LADWP and it's probably smud
they don't have as many employees as the
solar injury so that's again tells you
something pretty important because
because when you combine that with when
jobs chart here somewhere so sorry these
are out of order I don't know how that
happened anyway I don't miss this one I
can just talk you through when combined
with wind and EV work forces and the
Tesla plot employees did Mark tell you
probably about 13,000 people the clean
tech industry has added a whole new face
to the emerging 21st century workforce
at solarcity for example twenty percent
of the employees there are Latino that's
that is a statistic the tech world is
not likely to meet anytime soon and and
it really is a limitation of the
electronics kind of based industry
because these job numbers mean what they
always mean that the industry is gaining
political clout as well as popular
recognition because anytime you create
jobs you automatically have a little bit
of a halo over your head and you can you
have more political capital in whole
region's are being transformed by these
industries as they build plants to build
capacity like Fremont like Reno for the
gigafactory SolarCity's building a cup a
gigawatt scale plant in Buffalo which is
historically has had quite a quite a low
employment rate so this is all this is
this is going to change the way that we
you know we think of the American work
force overtime so those are some of the
good the good indicators we all remember
the Solyndra I'm sure you you've talked
about that where cleantech became a
dirty word the politics of moving from
fossil based economy to a clean energy
economy really got nasty and one of our
companies BrightSource energy which
makes large-scale solar thermal plants
tried to go public during that time and
fail I mean absolutely no one was
interested
even when SolarCity went public and you
saw that it's a four billion dollar
company today the price that we were
able to get on that IPO was so low that
instead of kind of jumping up and down
when the opening bell rang you know we
winced we thought wow people are getting
a real bargain here so it all worked out
but you know it was a very difficult
time at the same time as we felt that
under pressure we had a feeling we knew
that as the rest of the world began to
understand what amazing companies these
were and the number and quality of the
jobs the ability to provide consumers
with choice around their energy platform
and the ability to transform our economy
from 20th century needs to 21st century
needs we knew that there would be no
stopping this we thought that companies
we're not just offering an electric car
or a solar panel or an inverter to the
customer they were offering the customer
a no sacrifice ticket to the Future no
sacrifice on quality no sacrifice on
sustainability and that that was going
to be very potent so along the way as a
venture capitalist I've learned a few
things during the ups and the Downs and
the ups and the downs of this first
investing cycle and that really is is
that when people tell you you're crazy
you're nuts this is stupid why are you
doing that that you're probably on to
something and that you need you need to
kind of yeah you know assert yourself
and find find the strength to to keep
going on even though you've got a lot of
naysayers and it doesn't mean that every
deal you do or every job you have or
business you join or create is going to
be a Tesla or power light or a Solar
City but what I've learned is if you
stay true to your vision and you work
with like-minded folks and adapt as you
need to you'll achieve your goal sooner
or later even if it's not quite the goal
you started out with so that's that's
that's kind of what the journey that
we've had over the past 10 years and so
what does all that mean whether that
I'll signify so
it means that if you are in school
contemplating working in this field you
just need to remember it's bigger than
any of us ever thought or think now it
means that the stakes are higher the
resistance is way stronger the petite
but the potential for reward both
financial and social is at a scale we
never anticipated ten years ago and of
course there will be policy battles
incumbent tensions with the utilities
and such and even legal actions there
always are for a while until things
settle down and I it is what I to kind
of prove that point I want to take an
example from another company not a clean
tech tech company in our portfolio which
is Pandora the digital music company
that was a company that had its near
death moments at the same time that the
investment tax credit was not was not
being extended so 2007 2008 which if the
IDC had not been extended none of the
story would have ever happened SolarCity
powerlite no bet they all depended on
that back then but so Pandora had a
challenge back then because the record
label industry did not want digital
music to succeed and so they they
insisted on having royalties so high for
the music that was played on internet
radio that it would have put every
internet music company out of business
and so you can imagine the that year in
our investment committee meetings where
on the one hand SolarCity was in danger
of failing because there was no
investment tax credit renewal and
Pandora was about to go down the tubes
because of royalty dispute and it oh and
true Pandora it had to be an act of
Congress that was the only way to solve
that problem and so its way that's a
pretty high bar when you have an
investment in the fledgling company so
what happened without going into the G
Hills a compromise was reached and
really now there's no turning back last
November more music was streamed that it
was downloaded for the first time and
that's that's not going
change I mean you'll have new entrance
you'll have changes to the players but
we're not going back to just downloading
and we're certainly not going back to
just terrestrial radio so those lines
are not going to uncross going forward
and so in cleantech it's it's very
similar no matter how turbulent today
may seem going forward we're really
approaching that inflection point where
there is no turning back where that we
feel that there's an inexorable shift
toward a cleaner more distributed and
more integrated electricity system and
that becomes not alternative it becomes
the preferred path in fact we may have
reached this inflection point already
but as with most inflection points you
don't really know you're in them until
you look back but just a few facts that
you that you may may have heard in other
classes just to show you how things are
changing for example this summer in
August a hundred percent of new
generation capacity in the US came from
renewables for the first six months of
this year oh just about sixty percent of
all new generation capacity built in our
country was from renewables so I mean
those are very important numbers and
globally renewables represented
approximately fifty-nine percent of net
additions to global power capacity as
well the impact of these trends is very
very significant for as many coal plants
and some nuclear plants closed and today
we just learned that the pilgrim nuclear
plant and I think it's in Plymouth
Massachusetts that's closing as these
big plants close as natural gas
continues to be volatile over the next
10 to 20 years renewables will represent
the dominant energy sources in many
places in the world and in the country
so this just shows you renewables growth
as a percentage of new generation and
there's the green a solar the blue is
wind and the dotted line is the the two
together and so those are those are
pretty stunning
trends that will just intensify over
time and then the next slide shows you
just the yeah the seventy percent of our
coal generation capacity is being
retired over the next few years due to
new ETA rules and that that that's going
to go up not not down this is yeah I'm
sorry this is just showing you the the
various sources of new generation which
which we we talked about with just for
your files and then the Knicks there's
the job slot sorry about that but just
to show you you know look at Tesla look
at Twitter look at solarcity this is
pretty counterintuitive people most
people don't realize just that that job
creation engine and then of course why
is all of this why are we seeing more
numbers increasing numbers for wind and
solar well it's because of cost curves
like these that are coming down in both
wind and solar so we're kind of living
this day two days perhaps some of you
are too from where I sit having
participated in some of these
world-changing innovations I look
forward and see that a whole nother
generation of innovation is on its way I
see investment trends away from fossil
fuels toward clean energy back in 2014 I
gave a talk to a group that represented
a lot of the nation's endowment officers
for universities and I gave him a long
game like an hour lecture about how the
divest reinvest movement it wasn't
really about all the you know students
demonstrating outside your door it's
about investing in innovation and that
you need to move from one cycle to the
other in order to make money for your
institution it's like imagine if you had
held on to all your mainframe computer
stocks
when the mini computer and the the
desktop and now and then finally Apple
portable personal computers were built I
mean you would have lost a lot of money
hanging on to those kind of dinosaurs
and you might have been fired so I made
a whole speech that really showed that
you can't do that in other sectors and
you shouldn't do it an electricity and
energy either because you're going to
face the same peril and so we do and
that's forward to today I mean when I
made that speech I think there was only
a like less than 50 million divested and
today it stands at two point six
trillion so that's a movement a lot of
people poo-pooed and yet extremely fast
growing in terms of the numbers so
changes in popular sentiment changes in
investment paradigms are propelling the
next generation of startups that are
built on the backs of the first
generation that we've talked about and
pushing us even further into a clean
energy future so I want to just talk
briefly about five of the areas that
we're excited about and how they fit
into this inflection point I was talking
about so storage and new area New Age
microgrids there should be a new
international markets big data space age
and circular economy or kind of five of
our themes so energy storage and New Age
microgrids really this is not your your
grandfather's or your County Hospital
micro grid where you just have a bunch
of generators in case the like the
electricity goes off and you need to
make sure the hospital still running
this these are micro grids that are very
sophisticated incorporate demand
response solar storage so that you can
take your power from the grid when you
need it and when it's cheap or you can
take it from your battery when that's
cheapest or you can take it from your
solar when that's firing on all
cylinders and and that utility will help
you make these decisions they're
sophisticated software to turn things on
and off and in a way that builds grid
strength and that automatically saves
you money in terms of your electricity
bill so it's a very very compelling
financial equation as well as good for
the
Armand there was one of our company's
advanced micro grid solutions that makes
these micro grids just had an
announcement yesterday where the irvine
company the largest one of the largest
and leading land companies in our
country down in Southern California
they're putting a bunch of their office
parks on a micro grid where they're
going to have Tesla batteries we're
going to have solar and then they're
going to have the grid and they're going
to have the software and they're just
going to get the power from wherever it
makes sense and they're going to the
river island company projects that it
will reduce its its power bill by about
twenty-five percent so these are here
and now this they're doing 10 gig 10
megawatts and then they're going to do
40 more over the next few years so it's
not demos it's not pilots you know this
is really something that's that's here
to say because storage allows you just
what you couldn't do before you always
had to build peakers to deal with the
hottest days of the year where everyone
had their air conditioned on but now you
have to do that because you can store
story energy another thing that we and
this just shows you where some of the
the leading kind of new-age micro grid
projects are international there are
over a billion people on our planet that
don't have electricity it's kind of hard
to imagine in this day and age but many
of the world's poor just do not have
access to electricity or in the end then
the whole whole nother group has access
to very intermittent electricity many
places in the developing world
electricity goes off several times a
week so what do you do there there have
been a lot of NGOs a lot of nut for
profits that have you know brought solar
lanterns to Africa and and and that's
all been very encouraging but in order
to scale you know to take out a billion
people you need to invest you need to
have companies you know even the Gates
Foundation doesn't have enough money to
write a grant where they're going to be
able to power a whole continent you know
forever so you need the private sector
to come in and build on what the NGOs
have
belt there and that and the benefit is
not just that you can do it now at the
same price as a kerosene lamp for
example but you also avoid a huge health
risk because kerosene is is a very
unhealthy product to have in your school
or your house and so we're going to
announce there's a big white house
conference next week which we didn't
know about but it's on off-grid how to
get power to off-grid folks and you can
turn it we're going to this is the
company that we're going to announce
we've invested in its up in San
Francisco it's called off-grid electric
and they they are serving Tanzania as
the first country and that the largest
really company in working in tons in the
end and they plan to move to to other
countries and we learned about it
because SolarCity one of our investments
and where I'm on the board they thought
it was such an interesting company that
they invested in a few years ago as a
strategic way to learn what was going on
in the developing world and then they
needed a new round of investment of me
they came to us so this records for us
this is our this is a big deal because
we've never invested we're just domestic
was the first time we've invested in an
African company so we're very excited
about that and that again it's a huge
opportunity another opportunity is just
the ability of big data natural to apply
to AG and food a lot of activity here
drones big data analysis mobile web
really allowing farmers to get
information about their own County and
what seeds are working where people you
know how our yields when people water
less or water more or use you know who
uses less energy whose is who uses more
does that have any correlation to crop
out the cropped output and so that is
something that you couldn't really know
before because you can collect that
information and crunch it without being
very tedious and expensive so now that's
cheap it's easy farmers have iPads they
have monitors on their tractors they've
been collecting this information
for decades but they haven't done
anything with it and a lot of it has
gone to you know the large corporations
who then use that information to sell
their own products like it's in the
interest of a seed company to say oh you
should plant 30 seats per row well what
if your data show you only need 20 and
that after you plant 20 you get a
suboptimal return on those additional 10
well that's what sometimes people are
learning and so to have that independent
information it's super important so
agricultural and natural resource
companies will be transformed by the
availability of cheap high quality data
another area that we're we're very
interested in is space and you may ask
well how its space related to climate
change lots of ways the you know we take
for granted that we know we can find out
anything we want on our phones by
hooking up to the Internet and that's
cheap and it's easy and it's
democratized everyone can do it that has
a phone well what if images of our
planet were cheap enough and good enough
and frequent enough so that you could
find out you know where where is carbon
moving throughout a region or where
where are pollutants the most intense on
a given 30 day period or if you're not
maybe not just climate change if you're
studying refugees you know where if you
could see where they're moving on a day
to day basis and just look that up on
your phone I'll listen you have much
better tools much better information
with which to solve whatever problem it
is you're trying to solve so we really
feel that the tools that small
satellites like are being designed at a
company called planetlab up in San
Francisco or mapping better mapping
tools will will allow future researchers
and activists to to get better data make
better decisions we also we're an
investor in space X you know we're kind
of sold on on Elon Musk and and
his approach the world like a safety
this and you may say well rockets are
not necessarily a climate change
investment but if you look at the way
what they're trying to do that every
time you see them try to lay on that
rocket on the the pad and the ocean that
is ushering in you know recycled rocket
parts which will make space travel a lot
less resource heavy and in the way that
you build them and allow you reuse we
use parts of the rocket which has an
environmental benefit which leads me to
our last category which is the circular
economy I mean we do need to use less
repurpose reuse and that it's the
sharing economy the circular economy
whatever you want to call it that's a
very dynamic field to invest in and it
can be recycling with micro grids
helping to recycle a wastewater and such
but it also has a very firm hold in the
retail and in consumer markets we've
invested in a few one is the real real
which is you know takes luxury goods and
allows you to consign them online and
authenticate that what you know you have
a Chanel bag that you want to sell I
don't Fenton hates that's the that it is
real and then you get seventy percent of
whatever you can sign for and these
products you don't have to buy new stuff
you just keep these products alive in
the marketplace for for many many cycles
and this is a company that's growing at
a very fast clip just because people
have a kind of an aspirational need to
not everybody but a lot of people want
to have nice things but they don't want
to buy them and maybe they can't afford
them new and so this is a way to kind of
democratize access and and save the
planet from kind of the onslaught of new
new goods all the time and then Yertle
takes it one step further that's another
company we've invested in where you're
not even using cash or just it's a
sharing economy you develop points
if you're you have a friend that just
had a baby who no longer needs to be in
the crib and you don't need all that
stuff you just put it on your goal and
someone will snatch it and not not have
to pay for it so it's a really nice as
long as they have accumulated year old
points so this is something that it
helps a lower income demographic
participate in the sharing economy so
these are just a few examples of areas
that we think will generate both great
investment returns and products and
services that are that are healthy for
the planet you can see it's a very
diverse list and yet the threads are
kind of tied together in a very
distinctively 21st century way unlike
sort of the 20th century not that it was
centralized command and control
monopolies opacity the 21st century not
is is all about distributed energy
portable it's and it's secured by themes
like choice competition and transparency
so you've got two very different styles
between the last century and our own you
know it's a world where resource
conservation renewables and storage
combined with the power to choose any
kind of energy footprint you want we're
clean distributed energy allows the
billion people in the world that don't
have electricity to turn on the lights
and more for the first time and where
it's a world where customers are members
or partners or anything but passive
ratepayers like our grandparents were
who were always on the receiving arm of
a predetermined energy grid service had
no choice in that so it's as I mentioned
our world is a world where farmers join
together they can use their collective
information to improve their crop yields
and their livelihoods while preserving
resources along the way and we're Space
Age tools format
being an imaging become as accessible as
listening to music on our smartphones
and finally it's a world where consumers
of all kinds can track and influence the
supply chain of anything they buy and
then keep the product that they've
bought in the economy for other people
to use instead of sending it into
landfills so just in closing kind of the
formal remarks here I would just say
that as you study here at Stanford and
you plan for your future I think it's
important to remember that you have the
ability to do something here that that's
very permanent and very large even
though kind of the use of social media
sometimes makes everything somewhat it
feels somewhat ephemeral this this field
is anything but that and with when you
if you choose I hope you do to jump into
it in some way you're really you should
think of yourselves is kind of being
part of the founding fathers and mothers
of the 21st century and it's really up
to us to to learn from the people that
have gone before us and to build on that
but to create a world that's not only
livable but is actually worth living in
and that's kind of the way that dbl is
structured and it's it's a future that
we think is very much doable and that
working together we can all we can o do
this so I hope that's given you just a
little bit of background of our approach
to investing of why we're so excited
about being able to continue to invest
in these entrepreneurs and how you might
think about your own lives and ways that
you might participate so with that
should we do Q&A here or should I just
say but before that thank you
I have the questions here I can go
through yeah so if you have questions
that you didn't submit or that you're
feeling burning you can ask the downward
and nancy has all this too quick that's
in so you started up by talking about
how TBL split off from jpmorgan all
right uh-huh so I don't worry if you
think that our ace if you could just
talk about the reason for splitting off
rather than stay part of JPMorgan's up
more instigated by the people who stayed
there people who left or it was sort of
a mutual yeah if you think there is some
sort of inherent conflict of interest
between I think that staying in
traditional policy well it's a good
question i mean certainly now you see
bain capital and Blackrock and Goldman
Sachs I mean everyone's kind of getting
involved in it but that and and I think
that's in general a good thing but back
back in 2008 it was not it was not
popular and and so what happened is that
when Jamie Dimon became the new CEO of
JPMorgan he just decided he wanted to
get rid of all the the third party owned
funds I mean which means funds like ours
where we had we had you know pension
funds we have banks we had foundations
as investors and he said I want the only
investment we do I want to be using bank
capital I don't want the risk of people
getting mad at us if we lose their money
so and so there were a lot of funds at
JP Morgan and so he just said ok we're
going to spin all of you out and so it
took us about a year and a half to
negotiate how exactly that was going to
happen and we we benefited because they
didn't think they didn't think our
portfolio was very valuable and at the
time it actually wasn't I mean we would
tell him about Tesla and we tell him
about solar city and all of these
Pandora and they would like yeah those
listening really risky very California
and like you know nice that you're doing
it Nancy but let's just want you to do
that on your own
so and I resisted it at first I mean I
didn't consider myself an entrepreneur
at the time I like backing entrepreneurs
but I work in the same place very very
unusual today but I work at a place that
had been a claw hammer from Chris was
acquired by JP Morgan right so I worked
in the same place for over 20 years so I
was very happy but sometimes you gotta
kind of get kicked out of the house and
so that's what happened and so in 2008
we we spun out and never looked back and
of course it was the right decision i
mean the meat that immediately after
doing it even though it was the worst
time to do it because the sep tember
downturn really was quite threatening to
a lot of our portfolio companies and to
us but even even with that downturn we
just felt we were able to express our
mission in a way that we couldn't as
part of a big international bank and
that was very liberating and powerful
please be very cultured um so how do you
address the you know the parts of the
country where power is achieved cost of
living is cheap water is cheap and you
know they're not necessarily the
traveling here you know expensive water
expensive power agriculture is smaller
waters show how how can one start a
company and deal with the naysayers
about like oh it's only it's only a
California problem well I mean there's a
reason why California has more solar
install than any other state so well a
lot of things start in California but
the way that you get around it being
just a California industry and and we're
seeing this I mean and it's not just a
Western interests industry anymore I
mean obviously Arizona Nevada Hawaii in
California have a lot of solar but so do
New Jersey and New York and
Massachusetts and the reason they're a
couple of things you in the early days
you started where electricity prices
were high so and where there was some
decent son
that's why California is such a great
place to grow the industry but with each
reduction in cost of solar all of a
sudden if electricity is you know 13
cents a kilowatt hour instead of you
know twenty cents as it isn't as it was
in California all of a sudden you could
sell into that state because the
economics of your solar lease of your
product you can make money even though
you're replacing a system that where
someone paid 13 cents and so it's kind
of like you one of the reasons that
solar is not big and rooftop solar is
not big in florida yet is because there
are you know some pretty cheap fossil
power there and there's also a whole
bunch of laws against rooftop in the
rooftop industry that would need to be
changed but it's it's just a matter of
time as the costs of renewables continue
to come down you know even if you don't
care about climate change you can make a
very intelligent financial decision to
switch to renewables because of the cost
argument so it's it's that classic
innovation has to drive down costs in
order to scale and then plow money back
into rd to drive down costs even further
that's kind of the virtuous cycle we're
in you need to do more impact investing
in developing countries what precautions
are you taking to ensure you get your
returns and places where the judicial
system may not favor litigation it
becomes that if they decide to edge out
shareholders yeah so we spent a lot of
time in fact we changed the the
governing you know how a lot of
corporations in our country have their
their corporate offices in Delaware
because the tax laws are good there so
there's a kind of a parallel step that
you take when you investing in an
international company make sure you it's
the core it's incorporated in that
country that has somewhat beneficial
laws so I think we moved from the
Seychelles to
some other some other country in the
African region in order to protect
ourselves more I mean there's no hundred
percent protection and you know we we
understand that once we invest one
hundred percent of our capital is at
risk of being lost but you know then you
do some of political assessment and
demographic assessment of these nations
and you figure out which ones are more
amenable to help households wanting to
have electric lighting and then which
ones it's just like your the previous
question there Tanzania's kind of the
California of Africa and then we'll go
to other countries just as we go to
other states as laws as prices as
political risk is evaluated and kind of
grow that way the question mr. strategy
finding out about new things like
probably now a lot of things come to you
but in you know the days where you just
it's fun out didn't you have to go out
and just really kind of be on top of
things and have had and how did you go
about that yes it's in fact Leslie
mentioned some of the places that we
still hang out there but we especially
you know the cleantech open the various
conferences out there oui oui it was
part of our mission anyway we wanted to
educate people about climate change but
it was also a way to increase our deal
flow is to seek out conferences business
plan competitions speaking at
University's Department of Energy
gatherings so that's that's been a big
part of our way to and enhance our deal
flow and then of course we get the
referrals from our existing
entrepreneurs which is also a great way
to do it but right now I would say I
mean we went thro well as I described in
this lender period but i would say i get
four or five deals a day but just come
in through email
what percentage you actually have done
oh it's like it's so hard I mean because
I'm like one of those neurotic people I
try to respond to all emails like
immediately and that's really hard to do
but we have a team now we have a system
we we asked for an executive summary we
put it into our dialogue we have weekly
meetings where we have new deals working
deals and and then portfolio companies
and so it I'm making it sound like it
all works very smoothly it doesn't but
that's in principle how we manage that
deal flow and it works it's just that
would work I feel like we're constantly
behind so if you send me a business plan
I will get to it but maybe not like
immediately people are going to be with
very technical background room if I'm
really honest and you rely on the
entrepreneurs to have technical
knowledge and be honest about what their
product does technically well an
entrepreneur by definition is always
going to be optimistic wait yeah well we
have some technical people but you can't
really have peps pessimistic people in
our industry because frankly you know
anything we look at it you could say
that is so not going to work so you have
to you kind of have an optimistic
outlook even though if it and then be
rigorous so we have a mix i went to
Stanford I was an anthropology major so
which I actually feel it's quite useful
because a lot of what we study a lot of
what we're dealing with our sub cultures
that are clashing and so that was kind
of what I learned about but we have
engineers we have a mechanical
engineering of electrical engineer I
actually did a lot in life sciences I
was a research assistant for the human
bio program that's still here right the
sort of life science core so but then
what you do is you build a network just
like you have a network of deals do you
have a network of people that will help
you analyze deals and sometimes you even
like if it's
super esoteric area you actually pay
someone a consultant to help you study a
deal so our business is so cottage it's
it's you know you just have to keep
track of everyone that you meet because
you'll probably need to ask that person
for something going forward and then you
give something to someone else I mean
you have to kind of has to be a two-way
street but i like having both technical
and and people that are I wouldn't say
they're non technical but they like I
have a much deeper understanding than
then one of the engineers on our team of
how policy works and how politics works
and well that's not important in many
deals it's important in in enough of
them and it's also something where we
can help our companies that those two
you know I would hate to miss one or the
other I think a diverse team is kind of
preferable oh you can be an excellent
talent as well as it's a nice can you
share with us Cupid
but you felt your work or partnership
with call seeds been most productive yes
we have a lot of good stories in our
early days and still we try to put
companies where when we can in
lower-income neighborhoods because we
believe as part of our mission is that
if you put an entrepreneurial company
that begins to succeed in a poor
neighborhood a lot of good things start
to happen in terms of there's a tax base
eventually they're hiring people those
people need lunch they need dry cleaning
I mean they so you kind of lift a
neighborhood out of poverty if all goes
well and so and we track all that we
measure job creation and we look at zip
codes that's that's kind of part of our
impact reporting in addition to our
financial reporting and so when it came
time to protest let to cite the model s
plan which is now the old nummi plant
and in fremont it's hard to believe but
around that board table a lot of the
pressure was anywhere about America and
especially anywhere by California it's
like let's go to Mexico let's go to Asia
let's you know let's go to the south
where labor costs are low and since our
mission as a firm was to create more
high-quality jobs in Northern California
we had a really small mission small fund
in those early days we were like well
wait a second maybe we could put that
plan in Northern California and keep
those jobs in California in America and
so in order to make that compelling we
had to find some incentives and so in
this took years and the nummi plant was
like we gone through six or seven yeah
deals but we got you know we got
workforce training dollars we got free
rent we got loans because we were we we
had something to sell we're going to
bring you some workers we're going to
help your help this troubled
neighborhood improve and so that big
companies do that a lot economic
development is is a pretty well-known
tool
but startup companies don't do it at all
I mean it's they don't have the talent
they don't have the expertise and so we
we kind of help Tesla realize that they
could they could get some policies that
would make it level a playing field and
that's eventually how the the nummi
plant was found and then Elon Musk so we
would never advocate that if it was
contrary to the business but it seemed
to us and then Elon became sort of more
kind of determined about this fact he
was like in those early days you need to
have manufacturing near rd in near
headquarters you know you don't want to
be jumping on a plane while you're doing
a revision on a car you know on a daily
basis and so we had that that help desk
the business the business need to be
close to st. Carlos which is where the
company used to be before moved to Palo
Alto that that was a nice fit for us and
so together we we kind of joined forces
and made that happen and then and I'll
just tell you one thing we did last week
just to give you something current and
new so diversity is another one of our
areas of mission and you know we just
want to help make the investment world
look more like are you know the
demographics of our country make clean
tech you know make sure that we're
representing that we look like as
diverse as our nation is and so Solar
City which is in one of you asked about
net metering and you know there's a big
you know tensions x 50 is I mean it's
one of the nightmares of this industries
that all the tall sees at the state
level so it's like you do one thing in
New York and then you have to do
something in New Jersey that's a
different and and so these companies
spend an inordinate amount of an
ordinate amount of time and money
working these and and the whole that
just to answer the question that someone
had the the issue about net metering
it's not really a cost shift which is
what was reflected in the question it's
a revenue ship it's basically every
every time you get a solar customer that
net meters and sells power back to the
grid you
losing revenue if your PG&E and so you
have to come up with some way to make up
for that revenue by investing in other
things and a lot of utilities are
starting to do that like the storage the
Irvine Land Company thing that was a
socal led project so again I think all
of this is going to sort itself out but
the thing that happens is that it isn't
actually a cost shift because there are
a lot of benefits but the solar people
the solar homes are adding to the grid
you don't have to build as many
transmission lines you don't have to
upgrade your distribution system so
there's a lot of money saving that goes
on but the utilities often focus on oh
you're you're you're taking you're using
our grid and you're not paying for it
but it isn't exactly that's not the kind
of right way to look at it but so anyway
at the CPUC last week there was a
meeting on net metering and there was
also a meeting of the diversity task
force at that the Public Utilities
Commission which believe it or not we we
were a beneficiary of because we got an
investment from a utility because they
are pressured by the PUC to in even in
financial services which vc is to make
sure that they they hire enough women
minorities and veterans and so because
our firm was women-led we were able to
qualify for that program and so we've
always kind of tried to give back and
and encourage the Public Utilities
Commission to continue this program so
there were these two meetings going on
in Michael picker who's the president of
the PUC asked Lisa one of my colleagues
who was at the meeting to get up and
talk about a new about a firm and about
a project that he knew we had just done
and what we had done is we we had said
to SolarCity that you know they do all
of these tax equity funds and
securitizing of the leases the way to
bring down the cost of capital and so
they securitize those solar assets
usually it's like be of a
credit suisse Goldman I mean it'sit's
Wall Street banks that do these
securitizations and so we had worked
with SolarCity to say well why don't we
kind of do what the utilities are forced
to do but do it voluntarily because it's
kind of the right thing to do why don't
we find a minority broker to include in
our securitization that we did we did
this about a month ago and SolarCity
said hey that's a good idea let's do
that and so we worked and that the we
found one espinoza from abdo partners
which is a hispanic-owned broker in New
Jersey and he said yeah we found him on
the cpuc the public utility commission a
list of minority vendors and so he said
yeah oh this is great i'll join the
securitization and so we we told that
story when the president asked us to to
speak fruit you have like two minutes so
she told a lot faster than I did but he
so all of a sudden in everyone's nodding
and the Commissioner was like oh that's
great and meanwhile SolarCity is
fighting this battle with the PUC to
make rates you know positive to get net
metering right it's not a battle but
it's an extreme you know extremely
intense complication and all of a sudden
they looked great in front of these
these very powerful regulators and they
and ticker said something like wow
that's really great to see that the
solar industry is leading on this so
it's that kind of political goodwill and
for doing the right thing I mean that's
not why SolarCity did it but you can see
you you derive benefits for fighting
battles you really care about so and
that was just something that because we
had been a beneficiary we had the
knowledge of a program that I think no
one else in California knows about that
that's a venture capitalist and it's
like way way down to the weeds but that
that's an example of how when you have a
broader version of what you're trying to
accomplish you reach out to more
stakeholders that then can can build
build you a platform that is more robust
is our belief
that's the question of energy meeting
metering hi Paula so I understand the
purring investigated a distribution grid
is part of the appeal or a utility but
with sorter that didn't really
significantly more valuable in a
commercial heavy sector we have like the
the solar production Peaks along the
consumption theek whereas in a
residential heavy area you could
actually have a net energy production
during the day on a hot solar day and
think because nobody's home we use the
electricity whereas then so you need to
feed it back out into the transmission
lines during the during the day and then
when people get home at five to seven pm
you still have the issue with the
evening p yeah it's called the duck
curve know where you have a sort of the
juice goes way down where the production
goes up and it kind of then it all comes
together in the evening and that's the
Ducks head so the first thing to say is
all of that goes away as storage becomes
cheaper so the long term solution to all
of this gnashing of teeth is storage and
that's something utilities can make
money with just as they can make money
with electric vehicles so that's why I'm
kind of optimistic that we're just in
this kind of period that's not going to
last however since wheat storage is not
ubiquitous yet you do have the issue
where you don't have obviously you don't
have solar power at night and and so
people all solar homes are using the
grid but what you're what what's
happening is that still that while there
may be more than there isn't actually
more than we need usually on the grid
during the day and it's also cheaper and
you know you don't have to build as many
additional plants because you're able to
smooth out some of your needs with solar
and wind so it's still benefit to the
grid because it's just adding
free you know you know you're not paying
for any kind of fuel and it's it's and
especially in Cal you know especially
like a day like this where there's a
huge need for air conditioning in many
regions in the state then you're going
to start using you know you need as much
as you can so the studies that the
various utility Commission's have done
across the country they've they all come
to the same conclusion that it's kind of
a wash that yes they do they do still
use the grid but they also do good
things by selling back the solar and so
what's just complicated is that the
utilities make certain claims and the
solar industry makes certain claims and
so it's hard to navigate what's actually
true and that's what the pc is doing
right now they're studying this and
they're going to come out with
recommendations see I can
just go through a couple of these
questions that you wrote to me someone
asked you know what percentage of our
fund adventures have a social component
and I would say all of them it's just
that some of our deals do well and some
don't and so if you if the company fails
or is never grows to its full potential
it doesn't have as much social impact
because you're not creating as many jobs
and it's not able to change the world
how much is focused on climate change i
would say about two-thirds of our
portfolio has some relation to climate
and that will probably stay constant
constant percentage of anyone using
information uh well there's a company
called generation investments which is
led one of the leaders is Al Gore it's
in London although they have a new york
office they don't have an office here
they do public stocks and private and
they do everything with a sustainability
they define it very broadly but there
are a hundred percent but most of what
they do is is not venture it's public
public stocks so I would say in terms of
venture we're probably the highest
because we're larger than that a few
cleantech only funds out there are quite
small and our last fund was 400 million
so we're kind of a big big firm now
someone asked about how do you invest in
the larger startups versus the young
ones where the risk profiles are
different and is there over saturation
and it's basically you just kind of use
your portfolio theory you you make sure
that you know you don't have ten Tesla's
in your portfolio that would have been a
good thing but it is you know very high
risk and so you need to you need to make
sure you've got some capital intensive
ones you've got some capital light ones
once it'll take forever ones that
hopefully will only take a few years and
kind of use diversification to make sure
you're not overexposed and so while
we're not stage agnostic
we tend to invest earlier we will do
some later stage to kind of protect our
our returns like power light that was
kind of a light later stage investment
for us someone asked about the
developing world and I think I answer
that with OGE sorry are you finding the
average pay back on climate change of
his companies it's long longer and
that's why I see firms aren't jumping in
it's um I don't there's been a study of
it so i only have anecdotal evidence i
mean i think there is some of our
companies its heart like the capital
intense ones or the ones with a heavy
regulatory burden where you know you
have to get a permit to do this and then
the California Energy Commission has to
okay in the Department of Interior those
those are longer ones and those are
frankly harder to make a lot of money on
I mean not to say you can't make money
but they they're just longer and tougher
and so you know we would severely limit
the number of those we have in a
portfolio but having said that I mean
Tesla I think we invested at Tesla the
same came with this pandora and tesla
went public a year earlier and we've
also had some of our shortest holding
periods be clean tech companies so i'm
not and then like revolution foods i
mean you may have heard of that it's a
company that serves healthy lunches to
low-income schools it's kind of a poster
child for an impact company as it
addresses obesity and diabetes in in our
kids health it's in Oakland they they
have a high valuation but they've been
around i think they're going to come on
their tenth year and they're they're not
going to go public for a few years so
it's hard someone should do an analysis
that the problem is that during that
period of cylindrical tourists in the
clean tech venture industry that kind of
we're in and out and didn't really
represent the norm that if you counted
all of those because there were a lot of
failures your data would be
a skewed so I think we have to have a
little bit more of a normal period to
kind of figure out what the true holding
periods our own experience has been that
they aren't longer so and someone asked
is the cleantech investing outlook
improving and i would say definitively
yet definitely yes i think that the kind
of themes that I talked about the fact
that I get four or four or five deals a
day I mean it's definitely percolating
again which is wonderful to see now in
terms of who's investing the tourists
are gone but there are still some great
firms that are committed and then
strategics and international and family
offices all of a sudden those those are
some of our syndicate partners but that
didn't exist in the early days so like
anything you know if you if you work
long enough you attract a new group of
investors in and when when others have
been washed out so that's what's
happening what will help get increase
the climate for funding you know it's
basically more exits more stories more
jobs more more icons they don't have to
all go public but you know you need to
have a certain visibility of people
having the venture model working so that
that's what we're working for as well so
one of you was interested in how did I
get sort of more of a personal career
path and how did I get involved in
impact investing I you know you only
connect the dots in the rearview mirror
nothing was connected as I as it was
happening but the day after I graduated
from Stanford I actually went to work I
took a plane to Washington and I worked
as an intern for the Sierra Club and I
kind of it's always been a passion of
mine and then my father was a engineer
and a kind of but he was a patent
attorney but he was an inventor and so I
was you know we were always deployed to
help him manufacture various things that
he had him and then
in our basement and so I also had an
appreciation for entrepreneurship so I
think just along the way I've tried to
combine those and sometimes that didn't
work and I did I did internet investing
around the first calm wave but you know
as you work and you generate enough of a
network you're able to stitch things
together so that when the opportunity
presents itself then you can really
identify what has been kind of
germinating in your mind all along and
so that happened to me in 2001 where I
was still very active in politics with
our firm I ran our government affairs
but I was doing internet investing and
then all of a sudden the Bay Area
Council came which is a regional
business group that focuses on the bay
area's staying strong as a for business
they came and said all these
neighborhood groups are complaining that
during the dot-com boom the same old
neighborhoods in the Bay Area stayed
poor and that you know when Netscape
were or all these companies were formed
they are all in the same place and so
Richmond still poor oakland still poor
East Palo Alto back then was was still
poor and so they say we want so we want
to tell these neighborhood groups that
we're going to work with a professional
venture capitalist to put companies in
poor neighborhoods and that I mean I'm
oversimplifying what our theme was but I
was pretty much it and so that allowed
and so my boss said well Nancy no one
else wants to do that at HQ but it kind
of combines your two jobs you know
you're doing all this politics you're
doing investing and so why don't you
just take it kind of mash up kind of do
one job instead of having two jobs and
so you know if you wait long enough
things like that happen and you're able
to take advantage of them and so I just
jumped in and it really did answer I
mean I I think venture capital of any
flavor is a really fun challenging and
interesting job but to overlay the
social component and the environmental
component you know is it's not even a
job you know it's like a calling it's
just very very satisfying
oh we're done one of us until I get my
last questions if you were to embark on
a nice no actually I have an idea which
is and I know nothing about real estate
investing this is the sad part but if I
did I would do a double bottom line
invest real estate investment firm
because ten years ago when we have ested
in Pandora revolution foods is in
Auckland bright sources in Oakland and
now we have some companies in Hunters
Point and I can see like that's getting
better I if we had what if we had
invested in the neighborhoods that we
put our company or our companies were in
or we help them move to and help you
know helped develop anti gentrification
policies I mean all of that good stuff I
think we would have made a great return
on for our investors and and we would
have helped to to massage that
transition from really difficult
neighborhoods to productive
neighborhoods without without the the
damage of non-stop gentrification so
that's what my subpoena would be a real
estate double wildlife fund that that is
informed by where the entrepreneurs are
starting their companies because I think
hundreds point 10 years from now will be
a very different place than it is today
the problem is I know nothing about
relativity so I'd have to hire a team
thank you so well thank you very much is
in a row joy to talk to you
you